hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is Tuesday the tenth of every and you're
watching games but news in use the
proves that cake strata as as risky as
it is great another project is in
trouble and this time it's peter
molyneux scotus this to do developing
goddess 22cans has been going through
some turmoil with some staff leaving if
their own volition to work on other
things and others being asked to leave
as happens upon the completion of the
project the current core designer of
goddess conrad nezhinski has said he
doesn't believe the kickstarter promises
are achievable particularly those
involving multiplayer and the idea of
having a persistent world on top of that
even though the linux stretch goal was
reached with over a whopping five
hundred and twenty-five thousand pounds
pledged Molyneux doesn't see that one
happening because of current
developments demands although new staff
are being brought on board Molyneux has
said I would never do Kickstarter again
in the way that we did it during
kickstarter at the very start of a game
can be very challenging an inside source
told GameSpot that the game is quote a
failure and that the goddess kickstarter
will not be fulfilled and the team will
either quit their jobs or have been
moved on to a new project as for a group
that may be doing worse than Volney
though that one's up for your judgement
343 industries are still wrestling with
halo the master chief collection three
vol.3 were really keen to release a
controlled public beta test for a
content update to test the waters for
errors and see what it fixes but they've
decided not to go ahead with it although
the beta test would have been the first
of its kind the team has said they can
test it internally there's the hope that
this new major content update will fix
the issues of the base game and the
extra bugs introduced by the subsequent
content update we'll have to wait and
see on that one because they must have a
lot of sweet news on the horizon this
year because for the first time ever
they'll be holding their own III press
conference Bethesda's press
conference is going to fall on Sunday
jun 14 a day ahead of Microsoft's
opening III press conference though the
company haven't provided any further
details on what it is they'll be
announcing or revealing we can certainly
speculate buzz around fallout 4 has been
going on for more than two years at this
point and the publisher is also believed
to still be working on the new gym for
project which is titled simply as doom
it's also been over three years since
we've seen an Elder Scrolls game that we
actually want to play sorry Elder
Scrolls online let me know down in the
comments what you'd like to see Bethesda
announced personally i'd be really came
for the Elder Scrolls 6 you can head to
gain slot for more news on things like
all the evolved tips you could ever want
and some massive steam sales those are
all the things that I wanted to tell you
about today thanks for sticking around
and do remember I have more news for you
same time tomorrow